[Musique]
Devrions-nous enquêter Devrions-nous fermer votre
gueule avant de nous faire tuer tous les deux
Elle est irremplaçable Tous les meilleurs médecins
sont morts Je suis épuisé Je ne me souviens plus
qui est vivant et qui est-ce Je veux faire
un discours  les funérailles de mon père
pas de problème techniquement oui mais
pratiquement quand j'ai dit pas de problème ce que
je voulais dire n'était pas un problème ignorez-moi les
sosies je pense que les contrats se terminent nous avons besoin de
votre aide je vais devoir signaler cette
conversation menaçant de faire du mal ou d'
obstruer toute mémoire  Présidium dans le
processus de votre [ __ ] de visage vous
pouvez tous embrasser
mon cul russe commencé ne sentirez rien
cela prenons un vote ceux en faveur de
Terry vous animus Lee a essayé à côté de
vous